Yes sir - neat t-shirt.
Pretty cool. Are you alone or do you have some friends?
They will come up when the demo was done.
Excellent. That will be one minute 43 seconds,
but we'll let you do it anyway.
Okay. David Weinberger from the Harvard innovation Lab.
And another with which I have a potential conflict of
interest because they are great friends. Over to you guys.
Thank you. It's a thrill for our entire team to be here.
I'll say this is an historic occasion, the launch of the DPLA
It's really amazing to be here,
to be in the presence of these other sprinters is my head and heart are exploding with desire to interoperate.
It's thrilling.
So shelflife collaborative is proposing to projects, integrated one is Library cloud which shows the heavy
lifting, and ShelfLife, which is the  far more gregarious application that runs on top of it.
Libra cloud -- it manages metadata from collections,
and makes it through open APIs and open data.
The aim of Library Cloud is to take everything  that libraries no
and make it all available to the entire web ecosystem.
Including other sites
and services like Wikipedia that can take it up, but also to developers and innovators who built perhaps,
recommendation engines or a library analytics or other portals like ShelfLife or who knows what.
That's the whole point.
So Library Cloud currently has about 15 million items in it, which means metadata about items,
we don't collect content itself, including situation data,
non-iced from partner libraries which included free
public libraries and to University libraries.
We also have been gathering metadata about Web objects.
We think of Libra cloud as metadata -- Library Cloud  it takes metadata,
as value to it puts out into the world applications, to get up, feedback in and every turn,
that metadata gets more value,
amplified in Italian which means that the impact
and value of the DPLA  is also amplified.
So let's take a look at shelflife.
This by the way is a screen cast that we did in our hotel
over WiFi last night. But it's real stuff, you can come see it in our booth were of course go to our
Sprint project online
and spend as much time as you want poking at it.
Our ideas that we do get -- get to this site either by coming to DPLA.org
or maybe go to your local library site which it has a
embedded DPLA which it. Also to many of its services.
So it's -- widget.
Or other apps that we can perhaps interoperate with.
We did -- this is a page, when you click on something you're interested in,
in this case we got here because shelflife recommended Pluto files,
because it knows about what we've been doing and Library Cloud has a great deal of information about
the general ecology of interest.
So the first thing to notice about  Library Cloud is that it is -- ShelfLife is that it is a place.
We think it should be a place because we firmly believe
that the  DPLA is going to be a major Web destination.
But it's also a place because ShelfLife is just not a
place you go to look up something you know you want or to find something that you  didn't know you want,
which is wonderful when that happens.
It's also a place to spend some time, explore, browse, navigate, to contribute, to enhance, to learn,
and to share with other people,
because it's a social all the way through.
So this means it has to be accessible to everyone.
In fact, the DPLA has to be accessible to everyone, so we use the single most common understandable simple
user interface around, which are shelves.
If you prefer the now standard OPAC cover browser,
we can do that too, when we have covers.
So if the object that you're looking at is a book,
the width of the book indicates its page count.
Actually, it's -- represent its length.
But if it's online, then ShelfLife is a fully click
and play application. So you click  in this case,
we're going out to the open Library,
in fact using their embedded browser, so thank you,
open Library for everything you do. You are amazing.
If it's media, a video, same deal. You click on it, click and play, and you can watch it.
He same for audio and the same for webpages.
We have 50,000 Wikipedia pages about books for sample that you can click on.
So that's a lot of context, right?
These shells are in fact special. Special in three ways.
The first way is this is our attempt to integrate the five collections that we have,
all in one infinite bookshelf. Now,
you can facet these back to their original collections
because browsing by collection is a useful thing to do but with ShelfLife you can also facet them  so you see
only the content of your local library.
This is a pretty interesting way of combining the interest of the DPLA and local libraries.
Second way this is special  is at the depth of the color blue indicates community relevance
or we call shelve rank,
we can't live based on user interactions plus using that
and I Mize circulation data that we're getting from our contributors.
The third way this is special, the shelf, is that all items occur,
all works of culture occur in the context,
in fact they occur in multiple contexts is, even the brain is contextual.
That's what we do. So we allow you to put it on say,
the Pluto files, see it in multiple contexts.
One of the context is that is carefully prepared by special librarians, categorized,
click on the categories were any of them
and see this work with all the other items by
professional librarians but we also want to provide that
-- combine that with some of libraries with the wisdom of
users as well so you can see it in the context of what
other users intend or how they recommended works, bring them out of the long tail.
You can also create -- users can create collections, and our collections are very simple,
it's that easy to do, select some objects.
You make a collection, added to an existing one
or create a new one. Very simple, straightforward,
powerful and useful. If you notice down here, it says Chicago story nights.
That is in fact an extraMUROS collection, created by them.
When you click on it, it will take you to extraMUROS,
launch it, and you can use their beautiful browser.
So we provide a lot of contact with ShelfLife, that's what it's about.
The contact  works is not just other works.
The context is people as well. So shelflife is social, although it does all the way through.
Social, social, social. You can rate it,
you can draw things with stars, you can like it, you can follow it.
The following established as a longer-term relationship with the object,
so that you get notified when for example there are new
reviews or the author has published new work
or discussion you are in has been added to.
Or maybe Neil Degrasse Tyson is going to show up at your
local library and do a book check.
-- Book chat . This is how we have emphasized the social, we think that's hugely important.
One more way though that these balloons on the right
indicate that there's been some social activity around the object.
We drop you in immediately in place where you can
comment, read, start up a new topic.
We've been thinking is a possibility that perhaps
comments from libraries ought to be highlighted,
because we want to make sure that we gather as much of
what libraries know and as much as users, crowds, communities know as well. Make it all available.
So there's much, much more.
This is a little taste.
We encourage you to come to our booth
or go online to see the whole thing.
We hope that it gives you a sense of where we're going with this. This shelflife and library cloud a real,
they work, they scale,
but this is just the beginning of figuring out what this vision is.
That's figure -- figuring out that vision is something we have to do together. We would love to together.
With Sprint partners, with everybody here.
But the real opportunity we think for the DPLA  is not simply to connect people to works. That's revolutionary,
that's amazing. That will change the world.
But culture doesn't consist of people interaction with works.
The real opportunity for DPLA is connect people to people through works,
because that's how you create culture, that's how it is created. That's how it grows, that's how it's enhance,
that's how it enters our lives,
that's how culture comes to matter to us. And we think that is fully within the mission
and the hope that we heard today of the digital put --
Thank you.
Where's our team? Come on up.
Our team is joining us.
As we come down, a question appear? -- A question up here quick
Great. My name is Laura Parsons, and my question is,
obviously you're going to measure -- gather a lot of user data on this.
I'm wondering what your plans would be for that.
Which aspect of the plans? What were going to do with it? Privacy issues?
Yes, both of those things.
There are plenty of things -- we have all seen those
examples sites on the web's that do amazing things with
knowing what users are doing. Opt in, opt in,
let me say that again, ought in. -- opt in.
Amazon does amazing things as well.
There's lots of readers sites,
I'll be asleep Amazon is not an opt in -- obviously
Amazon is not an opt in example.
We think of opting in, default to protecting user privacy,
any of these circulars
and data that would take into Library Cloud for example
is entirely anonymous, no identifiers .
Date sample is only a day,
the IDs are entirely grander last.
-- Granule her eyes peers -- granularized.
Good question.
Other questions?
Comments?
Suggestions? [Laughter]
Because Library thing knows -- which we love
and who is one of our partners, first of all,
buying is an interesting proposition but leaving that
aside, Library thing which we love, many of us are users,
knows a huge amount about what users know,
what their preferences are, what they're saying, in fact,
we're getting -- we have social metadata from them
already, so for example, a library cloud,
we know how many people -- how many times a work is
mentioned in the Library Cloud discussion. Not who, how many times.
Library Cloud for all of its wonderfulness, doesn't know libraries. It knows what readers know,
it's fabulous at that.
But we want to make sure that none of the wisdom
or the metadata of libraries is left behind.
That's great. Sack?
Great work. It's incredible, it's amazing. Very well done. Thank you.
[Laughter] I'm working on Sunday similar
and I have one suggestion for you,
which is  consider integrating social rank it with
everything. And we have a recommendation with stars
and things like that, but for comments
and -- I like your idea of giving special emphasis to librarians comments,
and you could do something where you allow readers to
rank up the best comment so that you are only exposed to the highest quality things.
One of the problems with Internet is it's so chaotic and almost too Democratic.
So DPLA in this effort we need to figure out a way to  on stock -- ounce to Moxie with the kind of duration that
let -- librarians are best at.
Wonderful question, huge set of possibilities.
This is a problem that's been addressed by lots of sort of thinking.
The key things are member is bigger Remer -- this is an
open system, and especially with Liber -- Library Cloud,
if you want for sample, a different recognition engine,
you don't wake -- you don't like the way you have
different purpose -- deaf -- different preferences, wonderful.
Thank you. I know this was a huge team effort.
These join me in thanking the whole team.
[Applause]